all right we're back
we're back we're having problems with
this but we rebooted the computer and
just started up a new show
i mean because i didn't want the same
thing to say oculus part two because we
weren't really talking about oculus
anymore so
we really have no idea what's going on
it might drop
but the connection says it's good for
now for now
but um let's see how many people are in
here now
they're starting to come in but uh
people were
interested in the logan's run series
and um this is what you get if you buy
it it's got an inner sleeve
it has three discs
and it came with a
like a little insert
but um i i like the show i kind of liked
it better on second viewing
um i guess because i never saw it when
it came out
you know back in the 70s so
the first time i saw it i didn't really
have like a real tight
connection with it i guess but then
seeing it again i was kind of like
i was kind of remembering some of it and
you kind of have fond memories of it
in a way kind of like watching an old
star trek episode
but um it's good it's got heather
menzies in it
cutie and then that guy right there
that's that's them and then another dude
shows up
their android named ram that's him right
there
but you could tell that it was uh
in between star trek and star trek the
next generation a lot of the same
writers
um also kind of had a little bit of a
i could see some of the influences from
six million dollar man couldn't you see
that oh yeah big time
yeah so i'd probably put it right in
between
six million dollar man and star trek
that uh
and star trek the original series kind
of like that
which i have to go back and look at some
of the six million dollar man i mean i
don't really remember that much
most of the one i remember the [ __ ]
bionic bigfoot was tripping me out
everybody
yeah but uh
yeah i haven't seen six million dollar
man for years and years evidently
you can stream it on um amazon
prime i think they said it was 1.99 per
episode which
yeah it's worth it how many episodes are
they it's
you know let me see because like i said
there was the pilot which was like a
movie
which is what they did standard back
then they just kind of made
essentially a tv movie yeah the pilot
was almost two hours i think
yeah see how many but if it was popular
then it would go to series
there's 14 episodes okay
so it's just kind of like a half season
yeah
so it would cost 28 to see all of it
if you can get the the uh the dvd set
for less than 28 dollars then
you know you you want to go with that
well yeah that'll obviously be a much
better deal
but it's it's a nice set it looks like
this when the when was this printed
uh trying to see when this came out
can you see hell no that's way too small
yeah and it's dark in here not dark in
here i can't see [ __ ] in here
yeah it doesn't have a date on it it's
that like three-point type or some [ __ ]
yeah i would say this might be from like
the 2000s
yeah donald moffett who played ren rem
was also in the thing
yeah he was he was wasn't he he played
um i totally forgot about that
played copper what does his name copper
i can't remember
yeah that's right i forgot all about
that i did as well i knew he was
familiar yeah
we were wondering we we had a whole like
debate when ren was first introduced
whether those were really his eyebrows
or whether they just stuck them on there
you know yeah because they did kind of
seem like
messy spock like you know what i mean
like they were kind of like that but
they were
super unruly
[Laughter]
louise asked me what channel that was we
used to watch six million dollar man out
in california
i think it might have think it was nbc
wasn't it
i think that was nbc i have no idea so i
don't remember what channel that would
have been
probably nine or seven
nbc was channel seven i think
i don't know i don't know man it was a
long time ago dude in florida it was
yeah well at least in my part of florida
nbc was channel
two channel two yeah and cbs was six and
abc was nine
in california cbs with channel two
nbc might have been channel four i think
nbc got moved to four later on
like when we got cable but when we first
when we just had
the three channels actually four
channels because we had pbs
it was nbc was two cbs was six abc was
nine
and pbs was 24.
and that's the only channels there was
and then we had
um then fox came along and that was
channel 35.
i don't even think broadcast television
exists anymore does it there's no
broadcast tv no it's all digital it's
all gone yeah
i mean that i don't know there might be
but i doubt it i think it's going i
don't i don't even think that there's
do we even have the [ __ ]
infrastructure for that anymore no i
don't think so i think installed
that would be that would be totally
energy inefficient too
to broadcast you know i mean that [ __ ]
it's so crazy to me to think about
nowadays that
i mean remember back in the old days if
you missed something like i said there
was a really creepy like oh there's a
cool like
uh made for tv horror movie and you
wanted to see it and then you missed it
and you just wouldn't get to see it yeah
because i'm not gonna rerun the [ __ ] you
missed it they're like
tough wouldn't rerun it even vhs wasn't
really
widespread not really yeah i mean we
didn't really have a vhs until
maybe the early to mid 80s maybe 84. i
didn't own one personally until the
early 90s and i went in the army
yeah then you could buy like a samsung
television that had a vhs player
underneath the bottom of it for like 300
bucks yeah we have one of those
yeah i think we're like 300 bucks maybe
250. they were it was really expensive
yeah back in the whole days because even
i
i think when we were a kid now we had a
betamax for a while three
two two fifty three hundred that was
cheap compared to what i was used to
when we were
when a kid when we were a kid that was
like a thousand dollars yeah for a vhs
player
and like i said when betamax because
that kind of came out a little bit first
and so we had one of those it i'm pretty
sure i mean my dad bought it
used i think like maybe off the back of
a van known him but um
because he was always looking out for
the bargains you know but um
yeah it was a really really lot of money
that he's and then
the thing about it we had the betamax
for a while and
he would record stuff but then after a
while it became clear that betamax
wasn't going anywhere
yeah and it was funny because i think my
uncle had a betamax too and he was just
adamant that he was that he had spent so
much money
on it and he was not gonna get a vhs
player
so i'm gonna keep the betamax so he had
a betamax like way after like nobody had
a baymax anymore
because he was just so mad that he'd
paid so much money for it that like
it just kind of like went down the
toilet yeah
so yeah it was pretty good series logan
5 and jessica 6
they had the damn robot it was kind of
like data the robot
the robot um
sears a robot they made sure to put
hotties in every episode
uh they had those [ __ ] silly ass
looking sandman guns that was like a
butane lighter that just went
shh
and it could do pretty much anything you
needed it to do it had a stun setting
in the time period yeah it had a stun it
also had a let's burn a hole in the
concrete wall setting
yeah um it was it was like a phaser
yeah phaser did the same thing that's
true um
can we talk a little bit i think we i
think we talked about this when we
reviewed this show a long time ago can
we talk about the theme song
oh yeah man the theme song is [ __ ]
this is a [ __ ] trip
because it's it's a decent
theme song it would be a normal decent
70s theme song right
but then laid over it is is basically a
[ __ ] sound effect that is
it's literally pew pew pew pew pew
pew yeah and it's really loud
yeah and it kind of kind of mars
it kind of mars the [ __ ] theme song
but me and jenny were talking about it
that's that theme song was so 70s
the only thing that differentiated it
from other sevens from like the love
boat or
from the love boat or something would
have been the damn [ __ ] pew pew pew
yeah because like look it's sci-fi so we
have to put a little bit of a sci-fi
spin on it so it sounds like the love
boat it kind of sounds like that
yeah not exactly but then put pew pew
pew and then the funny thing about it is
that the pew pew pew is like really
really loud
yeah and then it's like it's really
obnoxious and then it goes up a register
and then it gets louder like it's even
more like pew pew pew
like god damn assaulting me with the pew
pew
they're telling the kids from the
[ __ ] get-go that it's got [ __ ]
lasers in it
yeah because i remember that's the last
i remember in the [ __ ] 70s
what differentiated [ __ ] star wars
from everything else is they [ __ ] had
lasers man laser beams you could if you
could do a laser beam that you were
[ __ ] bad ass your whole show was
badass
battlestar galactica came out with
[ __ ] laser beams
[ __ ] incredible looking laser beams
they're trying to tell you what [ __ ]
they got
it's got lasers which it kind of doesn't
not really the stun setting [ __ ] shot
a blue beam out that would [ __ ]
freeze you but not the kill setting it
just went
like a butane lighter and then like you
had a firework explosion on the other
end
yeah like a laser yeah because lasers
are invisible
you know well yeah but that's not you
can't really put that in a movie because
it's like
well that's what they did it was
invisible yeah typical
setting rick shaw said logan and the pew
pew pews yeah
that's that's the band that performed
the theater yeah now another thing that
was [ __ ] trip about the
program is that it features two vehicles
a lot the sandman vehicle
which is a car it's a bubble car and it
looks really good
but then logan and jessica and and ram
are running around
in this abomination of a [ __ ] vehicle
it's supposed to be a solar-powered
hovercraft
they find it in the pilot episode which
makes sense because
they wanted a vehicle that was kind of
like the enterprise you didn't have to
refuel it you know you could go on it
logan's run is like
logan's trek it's like star trek
their version of the enterprise was that
dab vehicle
and it looked like a pregnant guppy gray
pregnant gruppy with like one of the
worst [ __ ]
futuristic symbols on it ever and it was
solar-powered it had it down
[ __ ] looked like a damn
what do you call a thing a [ __ ]
terrarium on the top of it like a green
it had like a little bit of a tank kind
of vibe too it's very square
imagine a a tank a a guppy and a green
house all had a [ __ ] baby
and it's it's it's a hovercraft but you
never really see it hover
it's just got wheels and some skirts
yeah it's kind of another way
like a bed skirt yeah when it goes it
[ __ ] lit it goes down
yeah like that and uh
it's got a sliding door [ __ ] the
ankles on the windows don't make any
goddamn sense it's not sleek at all
it looks like you wouldn't be able to
see out of it was my issue looked like a
little minivan and then when
when you looked inside you could see all
the [ __ ] seats and the upholstery it
was like straight out of like a lincoln
continental
yeah i told them i was like oh i said it
was nice to have fine corinthian leather
inside the inside of the space solar car
yeah because i said it look it looks
exactly like the seats in my granddad's
cattle
yeah 1976.
it's like red leather upholstery yeah
like a
like mahogany kind of uh yeah like a
brownish leather
but you know you could tell they were
one-off custom cars
you know uh for the day they were i
guess they were probably it was possible
pretty cool although the uh the sandman
car was a lot better than uh
it did look a lot cooler and it looked
like the visibility was much better
because
the windshields were much larger it
looked like a vehicle you could really
use
yeah the uh the solar powered hovercraft
didn't really look like a real vehicle
to me
true didn't look practical at all like
you couldn't really back that up and
i i don't remember did it have weapons
on it i think it did have weapons on it
didn't it
wait does it didn't they blow no they
didn't no they blow
they blew the door open with a damn hand
yeah
that's how they got it i mean why why
would the cars need to have guns on them
if you have the phaser that can do
everything well another thing is is that
you don't want to arm the damn vehicle
because then it would solve too many
problems in the movie
yeah it would be an unfair advantage
because yeah because you just try to
drive into the village of bad guys and
just be like just take everybody out
well they're being chased by the salmon
in the little sandman bubble car all you
do is turn it around just shoot them
but i have to i have to see the rest of
the series you know i don't know maybe
maybe they add weapons to it later i
don't know i
it was a pretty good series it's kind of
like star trek
each episode is like kind of like a
monster of the week type of deal or
situation of the week
um kind of had elements of mad max
because it's
it's post-apocalyptic and some of the
sets
kind of look like something that was
ripped off from um
planet of the apes yeah that one little
um
uh what do you call a thing
it was like a little arena it was like
an arena that arena looked like
something from planet of the apes which
might have been something sitting around
the back of universal studios a lot
yeah it may have been kind of adobe
looking yeah it did look like
yeah that one of that because i yeah i
haven't seen the planet of the apes
movies in a long time but i do feel like
that looked like something that was like
some kind of little arena shot
every now and then they'll do it like a
map shot but that was the that was the
pilot wasn't it
yeah yeah the pilot was i think better
than the series the
the episode so far in the way in terms
of budget
but the story of each one so far has
been passable been pretty good
yeah and like i said they're kind of
standalone yeah story you can jump in at
any time
pretty much it doesn't really have to be
in a particular order because it's like
oh they just keep looking for sanctuary
and they think they find
it and then it's not that and it's like
it's kind of like wow it was like a
nuclear war or whatever it's like well
there's still a lot of people farting
around out there though
because they find a whole new city every
single week
like well this was all right here who
knew
you know they're talking about buck
rogers
yeah that's what i'm saying um i think
it was from the planet of the age tv
show
some of the stuff that they were using
because i remember the planet of the
apes
tv show and i think this came out after
planet of the apes tv show oh no i can't
remember my dad was watching planet of
the apes tv show and i remember that he
liked it at first but then after a few
episodes he was like
he scoffed at it and stopped watching it
i haven't seen
it so i don't i don't know what it's
like it might be good
i saw it but i don't really remember
anything about it
because i was little the other one the
one that i want to watch next after this
one is i want to see space 1999.
i never saw the whole series i just yeah
i don't think i did either
and i i saw an episode a few months back
and i was like this actually looks
pretty good
you know i had i had a british made
little diecast
uh toy of the the the lunar
ma some kind of like a lunar lander type
thing i don't remember what was called
from space 1999 yeah remember that had
the four legs it was long rockets in the
back and pointed
yeah yeah yeah and it had a little cargo
bay that would disconnect from it you
could leave it behind i had that
it was it was made in england it was
really [ __ ] really well made
die-cast metal with plastic they had a
bunch of different ones but i only had
the white one
i think they had they had different
versions of that spacecraft i forgot
what they were called somebody no
somebody in the comment section knows
what those things were called it was a
lunar
something or other speaking of which you
need to show your um
your thing that you oh yeah your present
that you got that's right
right back here probably re-mention this
on the main show
yeah we will michael michael sent this
to me
i don't know which michael we got four
of them says tom i saw this
on pre-order right after the show you
were talking about evil knievel jumping
a motorcycle that wasn't meant to get
airborne just had to order it enjoy
michael
that's it look how cute that is yeah
oh my god yep
the motorcycle's correct too well yeah
of course
yeah at that time eva was [ __ ]
jumping a
modified harley sportster maybe it might
have been xr750 which was a modified
sportster
um he started off on triumphs i think
i'll get you terry asked if we saw
farscape
i think i saw a few of the real early
episodes i saw them they were good
yeah i remember it being pretty good i
think i kind of lost interest after a
while but i did see
like the first probably the first season
i think i saw like a one quarter of them
and it was good i like i think they used
to be on the sci-fi channel though yeah
it was
yeah i thought it was it was pretty good
because i mean i was watching a lot of
sci-fi channel back then because that's
when
mst was on the sci-fi channel so
sometimes i would see far escape too
because it would be on after it graham
called it they were called the eagle
transporter that's right
that vehicle was called the eagle
transporter well we're gonna have to
watch space 1999 because i don't think
that i've ever seen it
they had this alien chick on there i
remember her think her name was myra or
mira
and uh she could turn into anything she
was a uh
handy she was yeah she could she could
morph into any other
animal or any kind of alien and alien
animals
you could see what she was going to
transform into in her eye they would
zoom in on her [ __ ] eye and you could
see what she was going to become and
then she would be that what do you call
it a
shape-shifter she was a shape-shifter
transmogrification yeah
i don't know if it happened in reality
or if it happened or if it happened in
your mind i don't know if it was an
illusion or not
like a glamour yeah but it uh but she
was able to do it
i think it happened i think she actually
transformed in reality
because she [ __ ] jump on something
dude and [ __ ] beat him up
she turned into like a [ __ ] you know
like like a mugatu
or something remember the mugatu from
[ __ ] star trek
the [ __ ] albino unicorn gorilla
oh yeah yeah yeah poison [ __ ] thing
she turned into stuff like that and get
you
i mean you think that you could just
turn into like a big huge boulder and
just like squish the dude
yeah yeah that'd be a lot easier
graham said her name was maya okay yeah
it's been a long time
she was a science officer
brave new world was a good movie i don't
really remember that one yeah it was
good
i like that book as well mango said that
[ __ ] back badgers said that
re-watched all the space 1999 recently
and it has some great stories
it's a good all-around show yeah we
definitely need to get to that one of
these days i got so much stuff i got to
watch
yeah i'm so behind well what's funny is
that
just because of the way [ __ ] is now
you're kind of better off going back in
time and looking at some of the old
classic stuff
because a lot of stuff they make now is
just like [ __ ] you know it's just
you don't really have any kind of
connection to it neither does anybody
else uh i heard that the new star trek
i haven't seen it i heard the new star
trek some
some people liked it because it's very
different than other star trek of course
they got to get around all these
licensing
fees they don't want to pay licensing so
they had to change everything
you know uh change the way everything
looked and the story you know
and i don't think it's taking place in
this universe it's taken place in a
parallel universe
it's supposed to be kind of dark and um
dark and pessimistic now that
star trek fans aren't gonna like that
that's just not what star trek was
so i think it's i think it's being
cancelled um
i like the my favorite star trek was the
one that every
everybody used to [ __ ] hate the worst
and that was enterprise i liked
enterprise
um which takes place before
the original series i like the original
series i have to say the original series
is probably my favorite but outside that
i liked enterprise i would
it wasn't that good the first season or
so but once it started to roll it got
better
um they started going down weird paths
and so they never really wrapped up the
temporal
the temporal time war or whatever they
never really
they never really sufficiently wrapped
that up there was some [ __ ] that was
going on in this weird expanse they
never really wrapped up
but it meant it at the end it had like
one of the best [ __ ]
mir two of the best mirror episodes of
all times when
it was it was in that which went all the
way back
to the old episode where the defiant
disappeared off into the damn [ __ ]
other dimension because the dalians took
it
well this this explains [ __ ] where it
went it was good
i like the series it has shran in it
you know played by old wes's name
jeffrey comes jeffrey combs i have to
tell him everything gotta kill him
[Laughter]
was in it would make [ __ ] appearances
i liked him well i mean jeffrey combs is
jeffy comes awesome [ __ ] so well i
love jeffrey
he was in deep space nine too and i
never really got off into all sp
deep space nine it never really uh there
were some good episodes that i saw but
i was never able to catch it in a
on a regular basis i think it says a lot
of times i was in the army or was
working you know
yeah so all right so
yeah you ready to wrap it up because
we've been going like a long time yeah
we've been going
like more than an hour because we had to
stop and then start back over again
but like i said that's kind of why i
retitled this one because
like i said we weren't talking about the
same thing anymore it was good
just kind of it was good just to
re-mention this one anyway because we
haven't mentioned this in a long time
and since we're back on it
and looking at it again just just
mentioning it again was i think
it was a good idea yeah it's a good
series
yeah it definitely is if you're into
that kind of stuff like that if you're
if you're into the original movie it's
definitely worth taking a look at yeah
all right so we will be back tomorrow
talking about another new movie probably
hopefully we won't have
any more [ __ ] problems like we had
today i don't know why we haven't had
any problems for like a week yeah
i don't know why it suddenly decided
maybe our wi-fi is [ __ ] up i don't
know
uh but yeah so we'll be back tomorrow at
3 p.m eastern standard time talking
about another movie
thanks everybody for dropping by bye